exactly yeah that whole yeah maybe it's
that whole whitewashing of certain
things that people got really offended
by cuz I understand that to a certain
extent yes like we're like we have these
foods that we were made fun of when were
younger but then you just one white chef
that tries to educate other people about
a food that was already ours it kind of
takes the the it's our spirit from our
food like our culture yeah if you use it
whenever you feel like it's okay to use
it yeah I think that's where people
begin a little weirded out by it right
it's like wait hold on a second I used
to get [ __ ] clowned on for that food
and now that you know you have you know
George pickle McPherson just he's over
here just telling people like Amen so
this is how you're gonna cook chow mein
and this is how it's gonna be when it's
authentic yeah that's the verbage where
it [ __ ] them up yes like maybe you
shouldn't have said the word authentic
said this is how I learned how to make
Chinese food from blah blah blah blah
yeah and this is this is this is my
version of it cool you know but then
when you say something like authenticity
with the culture who didn't even get to
own up to to the donis of it and you get
to take credit for it first yeah that's
where people start to feel a little
weird you know yeah I mean when I hear
that stuff too I'm also like he's
probably just talking to other white
people probably and I feel like that too
like that one white guy that was doing
remember he got a lot of flack for
[ __ ] uh this is how you make
authentic [ __ ] and all that to me what I
saw was a guy introducing Vietnamese
noodles to his culture not to me to why
people he was talking to other white
people that didn't know what this was
yeah so then I but I also see why
Vietnamese people were like what the
[ __ ] bro like that that's not you even
do it right or whatever you know and
then then it's like oh [ __ ] like maybe
you should have considered that the
whole world's a part of this [ __ ] but I
don't know man this is kind of weird
because you know that guy Ivan ramen oh
yeah he said well he's [ __ ] sick
right like I haven't tasted his stuff
but there's a man who dedicated he
speaks Japanese too by the way yeah he
speaks Japanese he opened a ramen so I
haven't ramens this Jewish guy from the
East Coast who went to Japan
fell in love with the culture and he
loved ramen so much that he worked at a
ramen shop paid his dues as an
apprentice built his own ramen shop
successful ramen shop - in Japan in
Japan he was covered in the Japanese
news and all that and people started you
know eating his ramen there then he
decided to come to the States and build
a shop and I was kind of thinking about
that and I'm like man that's pretty
interesting because here's a guy who
paid dues and he's dedicated his life to
ramen and then I'm japanese-american and
I haven't spent the time that he did but
if I opened up a ramen shop people will
look at me and say that's authentic
versus him because I'm Japanese right
and I'm like but is that really fair to
that guy though cuz he's paid a lot of
dues and he's actually lived in Japan
longer than I have yeah and he studied
under Japanese ramen guys so who's gonna
be more authentic I don't even know yeah
and you know when you say that - about
the fog I I could really understand him
maybe now that I look back at it - and I
agree with you I did a whole video about
it - why you parried it funny though
yeah I was like I understand because
it's just he probably was speaking to
other white people to make sure that
they don't [ __ ] it up yeah he was trying
to do a service to Asian people but it
came off wrong it came off like he knew
everything or like that's his [ __ ] yeah
you know like I don't know it's it's
just man when it comes to culture it's
soul it is man you got to be careful
especially if you're white and [ __ ] cuz
it's not really that guy that [ __ ] up
it's just all the people that's been
[ __ ] up there's a guy also - he owns
a joint called Pok Pok and Pok Pok is
his Thai place right this [ __ ]
goes to Thailand every [ __ ] year yeah
and he he speaks Thai he's a white first
of all dude Thai is a very hard language
in general and if for a white guy to
learn Thai and [ __ ] and he eats like all
the weird like real [ __ ] big coagulated
let's do it that dude that was like
sucking a period out of a pig's [ __ ] on
the hood this was eating some crazy [ __ ]
and then you know you'll read some
certain reviews like he's you know why
is this guy you know trying to represent
for Thai people he's not making real
authentic Thai food it was like well he
speaks Thai he goes every [ __ ] year
learned
from chefs over there you know pays due
respect to the culture make sure that
it's authentic as he could make it or
what his versions of it yeah it's like
what more do you want for the guy like
shed my coat I think cooking is is an
art in and of itself yeah you and it's
kind of weird for somebody to say to
somebody else like you can't do this
because you don't look like us that's
Jesus to me that seed that's yeah that's
racist to like coming from our side yeah
saying like oh you're Mexican you can't
be cooking Asian food or you don't know
authentic Asian food I'm all like I know
a lot of Mexican chefs at Chinese
restaurants that week so really they
could work to walk like a [ __ ]
you know lately Omo got glassy ass
[ __ ]
dude Alison um Sydney Australia and man
so it was like me Darion and and and and
knowing we were we did this seminar out
there and we had like probably one of
the best Thai foods outside of Thailand
like it was so [ __ ] good right and
then we're like man who's like who's the
owner and all that and then this white
guy pops out good I might literally
write this white guy comes out and we're
like yo man like compliments like this
is probably the best [ __ ] I've ever had
outside of like this is super real [ __ ]
yeah and he's like oh my god thank you
for saying that I appreciate it and he
was saying like you know if it's always
the Asians that tell me
it goes in and white people they I get
scolded by other white people I don't
know [ __ ] he's like he literally gets
scolded by white people that this isn't
authentic you know he's like dude the
cook that's in the kitchen right now
that guy's on a work visa like any and
he's like he's like so he he bet he
basically has this work program that he
rotates from Thailand and he I am him so
his wife is tied to so he goes out there
and then like every time they find like
a dope like street vendor or something
they're like oh my god this is so
freakin good you know and then they
they're like would you want to come to
America and then they'll come in I mean
Australia and then they'll work at his
restaurant and then teach his other Thai
cooks that are resident their trade dude
yeah and indeed so
every several months they get new new
cooks just coming in teaching them
different dishes so it's as authentic or
like yeah yeah because it's fresh and
it's like cooks that have like they're
just they you know they were just in
Thailand like a month ago hey my mouth
is watering that's just yeah so all the
stuff and he's constantly trying to
evolve and figure out like new stuff so
he's very passionate him his wife are
both passionate held there they live
there like half of the year because his
wife's family is out there yeah and um
so but but the funny thing is he was
saying like what people would stop him
and and they think he's like a worker
there they don't think that he owns them
and then they'll say like yeah you know
this was terrible this isn't authentic
and like people will complain to him
like they're like I've been at Island
and it's not I would you agree all the
chefs and they're just kind of so idk
what's going on you know that's so weird
though I mean people who are so loud
about food sometimes you guys just don't
know [ __ ] so shut the [ __ ] up look if
you look like that's the thing - if
something visually that's why I like
David Chang right when he was doing the
whole ugly delicious yeah it's like yo
the [ __ ] tastes [ __ ] good [ __ ] your
perception of what authenticity is yeah
which is something I really vibe with
does it taste good right that's yeah
that's all that matters yeah does it
taste good and you know we could like I
said we can go and talk about you know
paying respect to cultures or whatever
after that but just initially what it is
is how I feel about film - right before
you go in and watch a film before you go
ahead and you dissect this film from top
to bottom about the lighting the
cinematography watch it did you like it
yes or no start with that first yeah and
then you can go ahead and dissect it
after because you're not even giving
something a chance mhm and that's what I
just [ __ ] hate sometimes I also think
people have expectations or like so like
picky people they have a specific thing
that they want right or they expect
something to happen so even if
something's actually good because
they're not open to it they go that's
not what that's not good because that's
not what I wanted mm-hmm so I get it
like if you bite into a [ __ ] mango
you're expecting a mango not like a
hamburger right so like yeah yeah so
they might be surprised but at the same
time you
gotta be more open with food to enjoy
food yeah I had like for example like
I've had Korean food my whole life the
way that my mom made it right and if I
just base it off the way my mom made it
and but and not thought about how
something tastes then I would hate
everybody else's Korean food right but
there are certain restaurants in k-town
that make certain foods better than my
mom does Oh hands down yeah this is
their specialty yeah and I eat it and
I'm like look at my mom I do hear that a
lot though people are like oh my mom can
make it better yeah like they say they
[ __ ] all day I'm like then [ __ ] stay
at home and eat all day doing it yeah
that's how it is like certain like my
mommy's really great side dishes and I
think she makes better than other people
because they don't season as well but
there are certain things that I've eaten
at restaurants that I would eat their
food over my mom's like for a fact yeah
you know cuz they're just better at it
than my mom is my mom knows she doesn't
better than mine you know it's better
than mine and that's why she'll go out
and eat that instead of her own [ __ ] so
being open to these ideas about food is
very [ __ ] important yeah I can't I
can't really chill with picky eaters man
picky eaters are hard to enjoy life with
because food is like a big way of